imply that should be the case in case
says I don't support marriage the way
the laws are today right yeah but then
how else would you suggest raising
children
you can get married um without the
government like
um and the church yeah
it's probably I mean I don't I don't
really have a suggestion I think someone
should run for office and change the
laws but how do you get the laws to
change
if the government caters to women
well I I think like because I don't know
when I just think of it from a practical
perspective I just think until men stop
getting married the laws won't change
hmm
but then it's kind of weird though
they'll still like make men legally
married because then there's they put in
laws that if you live with a girl for so
long yeah so it's like it's like my men
try to walk away and then it's like the
government makes them do it anyway so
it's just kind of a shitty system to be
honest
um
yeah I don't know I think that's why he
doesn't give prescriptions because there
really isn't a good one there isn't a
good one but there is he does have an
example of something that worked right
and again it might not necessarily work
for him for what he did might not
necessarily work for everyone but it
might still work for a lot more people
then and is out there so obviously he's
he says he's a very Christian man right
I don't think he he no he doesn't he he
actually has no no I'm telling you he
says
he says there's like a clip of him and
he says I don't follow a particular
religion I would say he literally writes
in his book about the fact that he's he
believes in the full resurrection of
Jesus Christ okay yeah okay and um
obviously which to me and I think even
when he sort of rockstar last night I
don't think he follows a particular
Church though maybe no yeah I just mean
Christian is what okay
yeah yeah
um but you know again considering it's
worked out so well for him you know
going through the life of having that
Rockstar lifestyle and then finding
finding Jesus and then now it turns out
he's been married for 20 what I don't
know how many years it's worked out it
turns out that within religion when two
religious people get together and
they're actually practicing the faith
again marriage has lost a lot last
longer why isn't that something that he
preaches if that's do you think do you
think that works for everyone I don't
like I said I don't think it will work
for everybody that's why he doesn't
preach it but none of the stuff he says
will work for everyone that's that's but
that's why he doesn't give prescriptions
he says these are the tools but this is
what I said I don't think he's given
order to us because this isn't something
he talks about yeah I don't know I think
that's just like common sense but like
if you're religious pair up with a
religious person but like my parents
have been married I don't know 30 years
and my dad's not particularly religious
my mom is
like and so should they go around
telling everyone to do that no I'm just
not a big fan of telling people what to
do to be honest I think everyone thinks
they know everything very true yeah very
true I think that comes on to
the next topic oh that's weird because
people have started requesting advice
sessions from me
and it's hard because I'm like why I'm
like I mean if they wanted that bat like
because they want they want to pay I've
been thinking about this lately I'm like
they want to pay for it but then I can't
say I don't give advice
[Laughter]
well I think this comes on to the next
topic I want to talk about um which is
specifically the current pillars I'd say
of the red pool movement so that'll be
the Andrew chase the uh fresh and fit
roller tomasi and I'd say sneaker I love
it and sneako no because I look at
everything through an entertainment
perspective because that's like I would
consider myself an Entertainer yeah and
I just think they're very entertaining I
don't think you're wrong I do think
they're very entertaining however okay I
think
the problem I have with someone like
sneaker that I said he's a very insane
person I watched a lot of his videos
he's such a good interviewer too yeah
he's a good interviewer yeah I think I
do think over the last couple months I
do think his interviewing prowess have
reduced a bit
um but I think that's because he's going
a bit angry and so does it does it tend
to be as patient as it used to be yeah
but
I think he he's the same age to me so
he's he's 24 this year and
um
a problem with social media these days
is the fact that this is the first
generation in which people who
don't come from Rich families and to
actually make wealth themselves there's
a there's now a generation of people who
didn't have to become competent to
become successful right and so even
though he's competent when it comes to
you know YouTube and what he does I
don't think he's as well read uncertain
uncertain Concepts when it comes to Red
Book and so you'll see him going fresh
and fit people I would agree with that
yeah you'll see him debate people and
his arguments fall apart because he's
unable to substantiate no it's weird
it's like I know what he's trying to say
yeah yeah and but it comes with time you
have to be bad to get good of course of
course I definitely agree with that and
but my my main thing I wanted to say
that is
people I think people like this again
and Andrew take again I think is an
exceptionally smart Man based on what
he's he's done he's been able to take
over the Internet however the one time
who's actually pushed by someone who's
maybe more intellectual than he is his
arguments completely forward and he
divulged he um devolved into what what
can I have an example so basically he
was
um he had an interview with Hassan at
the Hassan ABI I'm not sure if you know
I don't know so he's like a political
um uh YouTuber a streamer
and
um her song was basically um speaking to
him about a a thing that he said about
women being bad drivers right and then
he was basically saying well someone was
waiting the stats show that women
actually better drivers and Men
it's actually he was wrong also
um women Drive less than one that's why
they're less insured so they actually
like they they pulled it back because
that's what happens a lot they'll
disprove him but they don't show the
entirety of his stat so in that case
it's women Drive less than men and
therefore they have less accidents but
they actually have more accidents based
on how much they drive and I would say
like I don't know there's just some
things like anecdotally I would believe
because like come on you're telling me
come on I mean I've never been an
accident no I just think every time
there's someone driving crazy it's
always a girl like every time I've been
like cut off crazy it's always some
girls she's on her phone she's not
paying attention like but I think it's
men men do make up the best and the
worst of society never in every single
uh strata so even though the best
drivers it wasn't directors I'm just
telling you by and large he was correct
okay they misrepresented that stat and
it was the same thing like he he did
that with an IQ where like they were
yeah yeah with that one yeah they picked
one woman who was like third on the list
rather than yeah yeah like like so a lot
of times they'll disprove him with a
stat where they don't like talk about
the entirety of the stats yeah it's like
the same thing with the body count like
you'd say oh that's the average but
that's like okay when you include 80
year old women sure yeah but the main
thing I wanted to say with that was
instead of being able to explain his
point you know explain why he was right
he devolved into what women on fresh and
fit do where they'll be like well I feel
like this is my true event so my truth
is is true which is eventually what he
ended up saying he was like my truth is
that women
um drive drive worse and I I think
that's the main one of the main problems
I have with these people is that
a lot of stuff they say they claim women
do they end up doing the same thing the
moment is any form of pushed back by
someone who seems to be more
intellectual than Leo so how is it that
you can
have this energy or say this they
understand it for people for example you
gave he was right no no I get what you
mean
no it's like I'd have to have a
different example I think I think what
they're saying is like okay I could see
10 studies telling me that the Earth is
flat but if I look up and the Earth is
round like I think it's round yeah